you recently shared online a picture of
yourself as a boy as a young man yes and
you're in the picture you're with
penthouse models and I looked at the
picture because I follow you online
you're very funny and this is a real
picture of you as a child yes with
penthouse models and I wanted to
understand how did you get a picture
with penthouse models at this age you
look like you're about 11 10 years old
12
h/h but with the growth spurt II look 11
okay all right okay let's let's take a
look at the picture and walk us through
it first of all who do you look like
there oh this is half comes ago knees
you know the go nice Oh Oswald Cobblepot
oh nice I'm the go nice Corey Feldman
The Goonies okay okay yes it looks like
Corey Feldman from the Guney usually if
any pick a safe any okay all right it's
just no one calls it go knees it's just
Goonies the Goonies yes thank you nice
yeah I look like the man from Goonies
yes and the child from Goonies very good
and why are you with these penthouses of
these penthouse models architects what
mister architects architects yes as a
child I always wanted to give my father
a nice birthday surprise and so I was
looking under his bed to find secrets
and I found a lot of magazines of her
architecture magazine it was called
penthouse and so I look on the back and
I said I wrote a letter on the address I
said please may I invite my father to a
party so he may meet some architects and
so they did invite us and then we went
to the party and it was very exciting
everyone's shirt was moist for some
reason and when I brought my father's
here he's like listen Flula we cannot
tell anyone about this party I cannot
take photos with these architects it
must be you and that's how you got a
picture with the architect yes
sweetheart degrees
[Laughter]